welcome to this video endless fighter
again 4 out of L thought four out of 11
is my squad not brand not brilliant
against the sky KS playing a classical
classical Dutch just try to play normal
moves okay hmm this is really great with
a 5 a-4 I don't know should I play a 3-2
have before but okay if I can play
before anyway that looks a bit strange
am in this particular situation okay
make sure he's not getting in a three ok
let's this isn't this just just nice for
wide pawn on f4 sir looking somewhat
weak yet do I just trade off stuff I
mean okay if I take maybe he plays a
pawn the porn capture okay I can also
just do this typical regrouping night to
d3 he basically has two nights that want
to go to reform and troll maybe he has
to or he will take her on d to anyway so
I don't need to catch on you formally
yeah this is this is such a strange
opening the classical Dutch it always
looks like like total nonsense for black
but somehow somehow it is still getting
some some activity going I don't want to
take on c5 really okay let's let's put
this to d3 on d3 I mean yeah then if
I've this is not as stupid as inch as it
looks at first yeah somehow somehow
black is not in terrible shape okay
where do I go if I go to e3 Bishop g5 I
have f4 okay I'm threatening maybe c5
yeah maybe t5 and yeah maybe I'm also
threatening to just grab only four but
it's a risky business or so I was usual
to give up the light squared Bishop when
you have fianchetto
tough rook c8 maybe I'm not sure about
this it's not so clear what he should do
okay i was i was thinking c 5s is right
and i think i should play it break open
the center yeah okay at least I have not
I don't have a big big choice now but
now I have a choice I can also take with
the night market this seems better i get
i get knight to e5 very likely at least
take one f6 tough position Knight to e5
is what I was talking about he's got a
knight on e4 as well but I'm able to
take it may be at a at a good moment
while I'm where he's not here he cannot
take money five not poor
that's an interesting move taking the d
file under control I taking you for is
definitely risky I don't see how I can't
get to the D file
rook f.3d three could be could be a way
to do it
and I don't see a movie as is crazy I
don't really see a good movie em push up
to d3 is very very strong and then then
you end up blundering to this stuff I
Datuk just idiotic when I came whatever
it's not this night f2 it's not the end
of the world I think with Bishop g5
maybe I have some some compensation yeah
what did Tara over the terrible wait
while Amy came
I dev to I can I could have taken
we should be sure to be three and what
what a weird situation it was really I
didn't have any any decent move there
this looks very shaky for me but I
really I don't see what exactly you
should do but it looks very shaky
something like that
I don't I simply don't see a movie
yeah I just outplayed me here check this
Bishop Bishop to be three was was very
strong the only hope is to do something
on the seventh yeah it's probably not
check not going to be a much danger
check 96 andrew h eight mate would be
virtually okay check white 45 okay this
is a deserved loss what a weird but a
weird game I mean I care okay well let's
let's start with this I mean here white
is certainly better this cannot really
be great but it's it's difficult really
difficult and I screwed this up
brilliant ok c 5 i'm so probably on the
right track computers also on +1 so I
mean really Santa is falling apart here
but what is what what was my mistake
really ok I took
or this is all this is also an night see
595
huh
hmm that's a very interesting very
interesting point here where I need to
attempt the door just a second all right
back yeah 95 this is really what I must
do a very interesting positional moment
gem yeah it's probably really the right
way to play I need to get rid of this
night and not put this on your fire
interesting something like that for for
example I can't even go here something
like that is just just better provide
now my bishop is far more effective and
those those pawns prove to be weak and I
am on the D file already so Bishop d3 is
not an issue anymore so he shouldn't
take this is probably better then I ever
tried I think it can even play look if
you won here and now i am already I've
already there on d1 so he does not get
in but should be three at any point very
interesting and maybe this is also note
here covering the Queen so that can
actually set up though the caption so
this wasn't wasn't really the the great
way to play yeah the comp just wants to
drop on e4 maybe I must do that maybe I
must I really I was a bit shocked I mean
I spent more than a minute and then
blundered to Queen B 6 I couldn't my I
couldn't really
I must do that also because the sun and
this might prepare an idea like that or
look see 3d three it is it is risky with
my open king but I probably must do it
and I'd c5 was most women and now I
really was in bad shape night see for
strong okay well okay I really had lost
the threat him and he always kept a big
advantage not check not leaving the
result much in doubt he had played some
some some worse moves at the end but ok
he was winning on time in any case and
was better on the 295 that's very
interesting ok thanks for watching